les jours se lèvent et marquent une
année bouleversante pour ses Ukrainiens
c'est loin des leurs en Angleterre qu'il
souligne cet effroyable l'anniversaire
nouvelle recrue de l'armée ukrainienne
ils prennent un moment pour se
recueillir à la mémoire de ceux qui sont
tombés au combat ils portent le même
uniforme
britannique et un homony Canadien
dit-il de les soutenir et je l'espère de
contribuer à leur offrir l'entraînement
dont ils ont besoin pendant qu'ils sont
ici pour qu'ils puissent défendre leur
vie et celles des innocents qui
subissent cette guerre
c'est que les soldats des deux pays sont
surtout ici pour guider les Ukrainiens
dans leur tout premier pas vers les
champs de bataille ici des instructeurs
canadiens en 5 ou recrues à manier leurs
armes
c'est la toute première fois qu'il tire
à balle réel sauf quelques exceptions
comme Vassili c'est un chasseur explique
celui qui s'est porté volontaire après
que trop de ses amis soient morts au
combat malgré les supplications de sa
femme et la pleurer dit-il c'est un pull
à loterie où je vis où je meurs
malgré sa familiarité avec les armes le
temps qu'il pourra passer avec les 170
formateurs Canadiens à prendre les
rudiments de la guerre et bref cinq
semaines à peine puis il sera de retour
en Ukraine et pourraient être déployé
sur le champ la plus grande des filles
et d'essayer de partager le plus
d'informations possibles à une courte
période de temps afin de permettre
au moins ukrainien de survivre en
théâtre et d'être capable de faire le
travail
du mieux possible
un travail comme celui de dégager une
ville après qu'elle ait été prise par
l'ennemi
pour l'instant les instructeurs
britanniques veulent surtout voir leur
jeune protégés se déplacer avec
assurance en équipe sans hésiter à
déclencher leurs armes
les combats en milieu urbains sont sans
doute qu'il y a de plus dangereux pour
un soldat et comment le voir en Ukraine
depuis maintenant un an c'est fort
probablement ce qui attend ces jeunes
recrues à leur retour au pays on est
encore loin de l'exécution idéale d'un
scénario de combat
les élèves ne sont pas seuls à devant
s'adapter la nature des combats qui font
rage en Ukraine forcent les maîtres à
repenser tout un chapitre de leur manuel
d'enseignement sur les champs de
bataille on joue selon les règles du nom
époque
je crois que tout le monde a été surpris
par l'ampleur et le degré de brutalité
des combats que l'on voit qu'en Ukraine
des combats que ces jeunes hommes
devinent à peine la peur les accompagne
mais une certitude aussi celle que
derrière le brouillard de la guerre il
n'y a que la victoire qui se profile
pour eux ici marie-eveda Radio-Canada
dans le sud-est de l'Angleterre